how you doing buddy hey rich good to see
you man thanks for thanks for taking my
question good buddy what do you got for
me tonight
well first of all i want to tell you
that i i think you're doing great work i
think you help a lot of people
and i really appreciate it yeah second
thing i gotta tell you
is that i came to know of you i'm one of
those people who came to know of you
through your
interview with uh andrew clayton
i know that categorizes me at a trad con
that's
okay anyway so
my question revolves around the iron
rule number six
that i'm struggling with
uh
what is the what is the sixth island
iron rule
a woman cannot love you the way uh you
uh expect her to be able to love you
yeah yeah okay yeah yeah and the fact
that they uh
they uh love transactionally uh uh
conditionally yeah okay uh
opportunistically yeah and uh
so uh
i'm not exactly red built i'm working on
it but i'm way far away from it but
in my mind i'm trying to figure this out
if if we're red pilled and we we see the
code in the matrix
and we understand that a woman cannot
reciprocate
love
the way we expect it to be
then uh uh
as red pill we're supposed to be then
able to
guard ourselves to protect ourselves to
prevent ourselves from getting
emotionally invested
in that woman because we know she can't
reciprocate
and so if so if that's our
mode of operation then i say well okay
so let me just deal with one thing at a
time because i know that you got a few
ideas here and i want to answer sort of
like one thing at a time so one of the
things you said is that you know a woman
can't love you in a way that you expect
or love you which is true right like
women love a man under the condition
that he's useful
chris rock said it in a stand-up
tambourine only women children and dogs
are loved un unconditionally men are
only loved under the condition they
provide something right so now that's
not to say that a woman can't love you
or that you can't love a woman right
like i love my girlfriend and she loves
me immensely
right but i'm acutely aware that if i
stop chasing excellence fall flat on my
ass i get fat i'm out of shape
you know i'm not able to make money
she's probably gonna bounce
and that's okay
right so it's like
you know the whole point of the red pill
is not to piss you off or not to like
you know get you the point where you
keep women at a distance or that you
don't like fall for them sort of thing
it's like no have like have a
relationship with a woman have a
relationship with multiple women if
that's what you want to do but just
understand their nature right
right right but i mean but if you know
up front that they cannot invest
emotionally in the way that you
need them to yeah it's not you know
why do i bother yeah it's not in
sickness and health until you know death
do us part sort of thing like you know
they
so i mean and so i i i i guess in some
ways i'm trying to avoid becoming
blackfield because i am starting to
become a distance from the whole idea of
investing emotionally in a woman
but then i say to myself well then
what's the point what's the point of any
of it if i if i can't it's like it's
like uh is it better to have a nice car
drive it for a while and and total it by
smashing it into a tree or is it better
to never have had the car at all
and so you know is it better to
emotionally invest in a woman no one
you're gonna knowing that she can't
reciprocate knowing that you're gonna
get hurt or is it better to not invest
emotionally in a woman at all and i
can't get i can't resolve it no you're
asking good questions and you're dealing
with the standard stuff that every trad
con that's been watching that side of
the internet always deals with when
they come across my stuff right like i
wasn't expecting andrew clavin's team to
call me up and say hey we don't you know
we want to have you on the show i was
like okay cool you know i'm happy to
talk about that i knew
most people weren't going to agree with
it but if somebody wanted to listen and
you know hear what i had to say cool so
you're at the point where you're like
okay this guy rich you know said some
interesting things and i want to check
it out and i've checked it out now and
now it makes sense but now i have this
new challenge you know that i'm dealing
with yeah
how old are you
oh don't ask please don't make me say
the number
i'm guessing 50s
uh 65 minutes okay good so
where do you live
all right at the moment i'm in north
carolina okay um and what are you coming
across in the dating landscape as you're
kind of out and about doing your thing
well you know uh i just got out i just
got out of an ltr just a few months ago
and i honestly got i'm not i haven't
been eager to jump back into anything
i'm not not naturally a plate spinner
but i do have you know i am able to uh
generate a little charisma when i'm
motivated uh what i guess what you guys
uh
uh
call game
uh we used to call uh just uh uh
charisma or or whatever but um
uh so i haven't been i haven't been even
trying to get back into the game but in
this area say uh
it's it's a religious area but uh
there's it's not like there's a
shortage of opportunities but that way
okay and
what happened with the last lady that
you were dating
why did that not work out
yeah well you know i mean
well it definitely uh became beta ties
no question about it even more so have
you read my book
i'm i'm
reading you and rolo right now i've
looked i've watched many many many of
your podcasts and i agree with
everything you say okay i'd say
i'm not i'm not exactly able to
implement it the way that i know it
should be
okay so you went through betterization
through a thousand concessions oh yeah
yeah and she got yeah she got bored and
and you know i i do i did all the wrong
things as far as you know trying to make
myself into something that i thought she
would appreciate more yeah
things so yeah she she eventually
bounced yeah well look i mean
you're kind of new to this and i mean
it's like teaching an old dog new new
tricks you come across the information
like oh [ __ ] that's interesting i
i kind of felt that and i kind of
experienced that but i just didn't
really know how to put a fine point on
it and now that i seen the fine point
it's like that kind of changes the game
a little bit and you look at the you
know you look at the game you look at
women you're like wow is this really
worth it basically is what you're asking
me
right
and i mean the truth of the matter is is
if you
still subscribe to old world thinking if
you still subscribe to plugged in
thinking
it's not worth it
right you can't
you can't spit up the red pill once
you've taken it it's like okay now
you've seen the code in the matrix you
know what things are all about
and if you if you understand women's
true nature and you accept it for what
it is and you play the game you know
sort of thing you'll be just fine dude
like there's lots of guys in my
community like we chop this up all the
time right like there's lots of guys in
my community like some guys are red
pilled some guys are maybe a little bit
black pill some you know some guys have
been called somewhat nihilistic but
they're not sort of thing and it's like
you know what you just kind of figure
out what works for you and where you are
in your life and that's all that
that's all that the concept of putting
yourself first really is it's like
what's good for non-stop what matters to
me what am i going to tolerate what am i
not going to tolerate when she starts to
try to better ties me and you know push
me through all these concessions i'm
going to resist and i'm going to hold my
frame right
look
dating women is a lot easier than
getting into long-term relationships
with women because when you're in a
long-term relationship you don't have
other options you're generally going to
go through the process of beta tization
it's just you know to what extent you
know like you're all going to go through
it
and
[Music]
there's higher risk involved right
because when you invite a woman into
your life if you start living with her
if you start living in a way that looks
like marriage to the state
she all of a sudden could be entitled to
half of your [ __ ] right you know if you
do it wrong or if things go
about you know the wrong way depending
on what state laws are so it's like okay
knowing all those facts and that you
know
you're basically marching through some
like
a tool shed
and it's windy outside maybe there's a
tornado coming and a bunch of sharp
things might you know fly off the wall
and hit you you kind of make a you know
decision and you know think yourself
okay well i'm going to navigate just a
little bit differently right
well so so
one of the things you said i think that
really answered the question was that
it is actually possible
to have a loving relationship even
though she's not one with a different
way than what you
want yeah absolutely man i've been you
know i've been with my girl for a while
you know she's a great chick she
compliments my life she's not the focus
of it
she does she ticks off all the boxes she
doesn't have you know the red flags that
i talk about in my chapter she's got a
lot of green flags that i talk about in
my new book sort of thing
right like
there's
there's there's good women out there
that you can have a relationship with
and you'll have a good experience if
you're a solid guy that's unplugged and
you got good frame and you know how to
navigate things properly right but i
mean like you can't walk into it blindly
thinking well i love her and she loves
me and you know we fell in love with
each other in that time when we watched
the sunset in cancun blah blah blah all
that stuff doesn't matter you know two
years down the road if you've lost your
job and you're not making any money or
something happens and then she's looking
around going well non-stop is not the
guy that i
signed up for
things have changed all of a sudden
kevin from sales looks better and she
starts talking to that guy instead and
bounces on you and you're gonna have to
be okay with that
yeah right well i guess what i have to
be okay with again trying to understand
what you're saying here is i have to be
okay with the fact
that i know that she cannot love me in
with the same capacity that i'm loving
her
she
she can love you in this
um
at the same capacity but not in the same
capacity right so 10 out of 10 you know
head over heels in love with her 10 out
of 10
head over heels in love with me okay
but she loves me differently than i love
her
right right but it's the same level of
love okay so
love is love in that regard but but it's
different in the regard why she's there
and why she loves you you know women
love men for what they are
yeah you know for what he can provide
and you have to be okay with that and
it's why i tell guys like don't sulk
over it don't be a little bitched sit
around watching like black pill content
crying about it if you're fat lose the
weight if you're poor make the money if
you're boring be captivating you know
find interesting hobbies if you don't
have influence be influential right it's
like that's that just happens to be what
women are attracted to but you don't do
it to get the girls you do it for
yourself because you want to be a top
shelf man well i think i mean again this
might be the trad con thing coming up
but i i think that
most men really want a deep meaningful
relationship with a woman they do
and they absolutely do you can't be sure
that she has the same sort of emotional
depth that you have it undermines your
confidence in that relationship yeah but
i mean look man
as
as long as a chick looks at you like
you're her best hypergamous option
all other guys will be invisible she
will she will truthfully be in love with
you but you have to be the kind of guy
that a woman is going to fall for right
i mean if you're not taking off all the
boxes for
then something else looks interesting to
her and she has a capacity to get it
because she's attractive enough and you
know she knows how to wiggle around sort
of thing she'll
potentially go get it you know sort of
thing and you just got to be okay with
that right it's like you know
women women are just that way like
that's just the way women are right and
you can't blame them because
evolutionary speaking if they didn't do
what was best for them and their
offspring they would they would have
died
right
so
it's you know it's a feature it's not a
bug of the system right
and if you understand the features of
the system then you're like okay well
i'm that guy anyway so whatever i mean
you know
and then
that's when you have a great experience
listen man
that's that's when you truthfully have a
great experience dealing with the
opposite sex is when you're the top
shelf guy you got good game you're
captivating your frame like you deal
with all that stuff it's like
if a chick gets out of line or she's got
a bunch of red flags that she's not
dealing with sort of thing then you
don't settle for you don't invite her
into your life you don't take vacations
with you you don't date her on a
long-term basis you know you look for a
better option you keep her at arm's
length maybe she's just the friends with
benefits i don't know
but it's incumbent upon you as a guy
to make these decisions for yourself and
what's best for you right nobody can
tell you what's best for you you need to
decide for yourself and that's all that
i'm trying to do here you know with
these podcasts and my book and
everything i'm doing is i'm trying to
give guys the knowledge and give them
the power to make the decisions for
themselves so they can have a better
experience at life as a guy right i mean
if you listen to me long enough i will
brainwash you into thinking for yourself
well i'll keep listening but
i've gotten a lot out of i've got a lot
of good stuff and i really appreciate
all you do thank you
all right buddy take care
see you man hey guys i really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you